Ethan and Andrew Clark Ethan and Andrew
coming at you boys oh they're over there
Missouri
you know Table Rock Brendan do gang gang
buzz buzz it's me and Ethan here in the
middle sounds like someone's Sardo
Algonquin Park PA in Central arterial
Norfolk true Oh close though it's Canada
so Tanner stayin candid we saw a bear
today hard hey I was and he said
hardcore what's hard for me bro shoutout
to the Algonquin nation dude first of
all those our native forefathers dude
talking about native North Americans
native Canadians yeah we stole their
land
yeah we last some of it dude and they
also gave a lot of it up for sugar and
liquor yeah that's what I put up a very
good fight um the whole would die again
I need the terms here dude what's
hardcore no blankets kill what you kill
what you eat you know I'm saying yeah
that ain't for me ain't that dude really
now I'll be a little rogue inside peace
we want to kill [ __ ] and then make fires
yeah a little outdoor thought while he's
[ __ ] killing the deer I'm just
working the background well that finish
drying wood around yeah I love that bark
together for no reason at all do we
really need that whatever rains over
there making wine out of berries and
stuff in a barrel the edge of the disk
off the edge of the fire dude I think
this man Canada beautiful okay it's
gonna be the next America a lot of
people are ahead in there already read
our article the other day about a lot of
people moving to Canada mm-hmm
and I think obviously the woods get them
all that last brother and if you want to
do some hardcore camping you and your
buddy get out there with a couple of
knives and see you falls asleep first
you know that's an old-school deal man I
like it
two men enter one man leaves you know I
like battle to the death of nature yeah
and also it's brave to be out there in
Jason Voorhees hunting ground brothers
his ground yeah have you been a camping
they like shade up camping yeah yeah I
mean camp beliefs too came outside of
the post office
dude we used to camp outside of the mall
and our town we would go there for the
on Saturday like a camp out overnight in
a tent and then go Sunday oh you gotta
go like mo like you'd like to stay and
sleep in Dick's Sporting Goods camping
we'd sleep in a tent outside and then go
back to the mall the second day the mall
was about 20 miles away from us if you
want big campers in here I grew up in
Denver so we used to camp all the time
and I hated it uh Kath I'm sure no my
parents left Vietnam so we'll never have
to camp again
there you go but you guys were right
camping that's living yeah we were
living yeah but living in Vietnam is
almost like camping in some areas I mean
there's more of it it's certainly more
of a survival element bamboo dee you
don't look like a camper out in the back
you broke em bro have you ever camp boy
without it but you never camp before I
mean they don't camp
you know camper I mean they look for the
Underground Railroad that's not yeah a
little more a little survival camp
outside for the New Jordans
suddenly a lot of life you will camping
outside a footlocker have a lot of black
outdoorsmen huh no that's not our thing
man we like it in the gym we keep it
right in the gym jeah made the opposite
a camping you mean keep it in the house
indoors Oh Derek's never sleeping on a
treadmill that's it boys mmm that's it
for today well dude we did it man Billy
I'm seeing a while dude you say that
every week Brenda do I miss you man
[Music]